and joining us on the mercedes-benz vans
phone line in advance of monday night
football in front of the 12s on a monday
night the seattle seahawks hosting the
new orleans saints and the man who is in
the middle of this defense as he has
been now for 10 nfl seasons he's in the
middle of his 10th campaign with the
seahawks he is bobby wagner how are you
bobby
i'm not good how are you i'm uh better
for talking to you when that is the
truth man i i love watching you play you
know that i tell that to you all the
time
so i just want to ask how are you a
different player than when you first
strolled into the nfl how are you
different
oh man uh
i would say i'm a lot smarter
a lot wiser
i think i
when i first got into the league i was
moving so fast and trying to you know be
everywhere and like my technique and my
footwork wasn't as crisp as it probably
is now
um
i've definitely grown as a leader
as a as a man and so
i would say those are probably the major
differences because it's you know it's
odd that you would say that because it
does seem like you're fast and
everywhere
even now even now bobby you know just
don't waste i don't waste steps i think
when i was uh when i was younger i
definitely wasted some steps but uh you
know now every step counts for me for
sure so uh where do you where where are
you guys in the season right now uh what
what would you rate your first third of
the season so far bobby wagner
i don't know if i'll have a rating but i
definitely feel like you know we're not
where we want to be obviously two and
four
is not where you know we planned on
being this season but you know i think
there's a lot of
opportunity for growth and a lot of
opportunity to to get better and i think
that's the
the thing that you kind of focus on is
just understanding that
uh you know we have the players that can
can really make an impact and really
change the season around but it's up to
us as players to um you know execute out
there on the field which i you know i'm
confident that we could do that um you
know for me and russ you know we've been
in this situation before
and so it's not something that's foreign
to us obviously you want to start in the
you want to put yourself in this hole
but you know it's good when you have
history on getting out of it i mean you
know speaking of a situation though that
russ has not been in before it's with an
earbud in his ear you know um coaching
essentially as he did on sunday night
football what's that like for you
to uh be on the sideline and russ is on
the sideline with you because the
offense is out there without him what's
that like yeah
it's definitely different you know um
it's amazing that he's gone this long
without having to miss any games you
know i think that that talks about how
uh how well he handles his body off the
field even the
the injury that he had it was like a
freak accident just you know hit his
hand on somebody's helmet and so uh
you know it's definitely a a different
feeling but you know you see russ engage
you see him still active mentally and
taking mental reps and you know he's
still working out crazy and so you know
whenever that hand is ready to go i
definitely feel like he's going to be
he's going to pick up right where he
left off do you think he'll be back
sooner rather than later i mean what are
you seeing so far behind the scenes that
you can um let us know you never put
anything past russ you know if they say
yeah four weeks it could be two if they
say eight could be four so you know russ
is constantly um you know defined the
odds
in many ways so i definitely feel like
uh you know whenever he does it it's
gonna be whatever clock that he had
right and then you you know it's
interesting you said you know russ and i
we've been in this situation before it
used to be you could you could name more
names right who used to be in the
situation before do you sometimes look
around the locker room and you say oh my
god i'm the og around here does that
ever kind of land on you that way yeah
100 you know i i go back to
when i first got into the league and i
told uh me bank that i was born in 90
and he looked at me like i was crazy
because you know he was born in like 84
or something like that and yeah i didn't
think that was a big deal until you know
now some guys are coming in and saying
they were born in 97 98
and i'm just like dang i've been around
that long
you know for for guys to be you know
born while i'm doing this so it's it's
uh
it's definitely an interesting feeling
but it's fun too because you get to
learn
um kind of a new generation and how they
think
so how do they think
what do you think um what do you got for
me on that
they definitely think different you know
what i mean you know they're into a lot
a lot more things that you know
i don't think i was interested in as far
as like just everything is centered
around social media and everything is
centered around
um twitter instagram those things i mean
obviously i have them but
you know i think there's more to life
and i think that come with maturity yeah
so as those guys get more mature i feel
like
they'll see you know they got to put
their phones down and go out there and
explore the world and talk to some
people in in their face instead of they
uh behind the phone huh
so you don't have a tick tock is that
what you're saying bobby wagner there's
nothing i do not have a tick tock
i do not have you got a clock you got a
clock in your head for trying to clock
somebody with fewer steps that's what
we've
just established right now is probably
not the one i'll get yeah you know it's
crazy trey lance you know of your
competition he's he was born in 2000
like that's a fact
i think my nephew was born in 2001.
oh my gosh oh yes it's uh i know crazy i
know how has the game changed has it in
10 years bobby at all yeah definitely um
i think the way that they i mean i think
every year at least from you know when i
got here
every year they've made the game in my
opinion
harder for detailed players um
you know as far as tackling or you know
how you can strike a quarterback how you
could strike an offensive player
and so you know a lot of those things
that that has changed um
you know you had to evolve as a defender
because
some of the things that they used to do
back in the day we can't do
um now you know it's a penalty but i do
say that it is nice that they changed
you know one real change was you know
the
the centers or the linemen um cutting
down field or on the outside plays that
definitely helps um you know the
defenders but you know i think the game
um
they make it a lot harder to tackle
because sometimes you know we're we're
moving so fast and to try to
you know hit a person in the perfect
spot is not always easy but
uh we always adjust
bobby wagner here on the rich eisen show
prior to monday night football what do
you think of the taunting re-emphasis
what do you think about the emphasis on
the taunting rule bobby what do you
think about that
i mean i understand uh why they want to
implement it but i think this game is a
emotional game it's a game play with a
lot of passion so sometimes
you know that passion just has to be let
out and so i'm not a huge fan of it i'm
not a huge fan i understand why they do
it but i'm not a fan of it because
uh you know if a guy has a good run or a
big head and he gets up and he flex
you know sometimes he's not even flexing
towards a player he's just flexing
because
you know he made a great play and you
know everybody sees a great play and to
be penalized for that um it's not
something that i feel
is right but you know i think they're
trying to work out the kinks and try to
figure out
uh you know what's excessive and what's
not and hopefully
um they get it get it situated
so um when you're we're talking about
change a lot about the game and stuff
like that what needs to change starting
monday night
for the seattle seahawks bobby wagner
give me something what do you got i
think we need to we need to execute all
four quarters i think that's the biggest
thing i think we show flashes in each of
the games where
you know we show our potential we show
we're capable of doing but we just
haven't put it together you know all
four quarters and so you know i think if
we do that and do the stuff that we're
capable of doing but over the the
duration of the entire game uh we'll be
fine that's why i'm confident that
you know we'll get this thing turned
around because we showed what we're
capable of doing when everybody is on at
the same time and so
um it's just about being focused um
communicating and executing at a high
level for the whole game do you give
messages to geno throughout the week at
all i mean what a tough spot that he's
in with russ out what are you yeah it's
definitely a tough spot you know you uh
you know you have conf uh you have
conversations with him but at the end of
the day i definitely feel like geno's
you know handled himself very very well
he's very confident and you know i've
said this before like if
you know if you came in and watched him
prepare you wouldn't think that he
wasn't the starting quarterback he
prepared that he was starting
quarterback so that's why
you know when he came in after russ got
hurt uh he was ready for his opportunity
ready for his moment so you know i think
it's just going to take a little bit of
time but i'm definitely confident that
gino
you know is going to uh you know ball
out this game and then what is the
challenge with the saints coming off
their bye week for you bobby
i assume you're circling 41 um in the in
the meeting rooms i mean
what do you what do you have for me on
that front yeah you're definitely paying
attention to 41 i think that that is the
beginning of the offense you know i
think they want to get the ball in his
hand whether it's
running the ball uh passing the ball you
know he's a very very special player so
you know we definitely have to have the
eyes for him
um you know jameis is going to do his
thing you see his growth
you know from he when he got into the
league to
that kind of brief period where he
wasn't in the league or he was a backup
quarterback you see him making
better decisions with the ball so
we just have to be on our job and
capitalize on mistakes when they happen
all right what do you do in your spare
time
bobby wagner what does bobby wagner do
in spare time
um
i learn i learn everything that i can
but i like to
get involved in business so whenever i'm
not uh whenever i'm not uh playing
football
i am either reading something towards
business um looking at investments um
being involved in the venture fund out
here named fuse
um in seattle okay and uh you know
figuring out ways to grow this wealth
that i've been blessed enough to
to get okay so you're you're looking
over the steering wheel about what
you're going to do whenever you stop
doing what you're currently doing
yes for sure i mean i i think um i
you know i've had a lot of great mentors
um
you know guide me in the right direction
so i've kind of been doing this for a
while i've been doing this since like
2013 so um
it's something that i i have a passion
for and whenever i decide to
walk away from this game not anytime
soon
uh you know i think i'll be in good
shape okay guys like gates is that bill
gates who is he counting he's he
counseling you is that who it is who
else i mean i haven't i haven't been
blessed enough to to meet uh bill gates
but i i feel like uh
you know putting you putting in a good
word i think i was sure get off that
door no no man i mean he might be you
call him i know i'll get in i don't know
you might be a neighbor of yours a lot
of you got a lot of rich people up there
in the in seattle you might be a
neighbor yours you know
i mean hopefully i mean i definitely run
into them but i'm saying if i get the
you know the rich approval then i know
it's gonna happen for sure okay yeah i
know a guy named bill um and and there's
a gate you know near my door in my house
that's about it
that's a
step in the right direction
and we're about saving steps that's what
this whole conversation's been about
please okay exactly all right bobby
wagner thanks for calling have a great
monday night football game let's do this
down the 2021 line thanks for the call
appreciate it appreciate it any time the
one and only bobby wagner right here
prior to monday night football between
the saints and the seahawks
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here